today's draft the best current
quarterback rivalries in the national
football league chris sims gets the
trivia question here it is christopher
peyton manning and tom brady played each
other 17 times during their careers they
were supposed to play in 2011 but peyton
missed the game due to his neck injury
who started that game for the colts at
quarterback what year was that say that
one more time
2011 the year that peyton manning didn't
play at all
oh 2011 gosh i can't think of his name
he was the real skinny quarterback and
i'm blanking out he played in the big
ten what the heck was his name
i can't think of it who is it
dan orlowski that's not who you're
thinking of no it was not who i was
thinking of i was thinking are you
thinking about this painter no there's a
bat
i know who you're thinking of the guy
from wisconsin yes i can't think of his
damn name
exactly right okay so our lobster
started i forgot about that one
yeah all right i get to go first and for
me this one's simple it's the last two
mvps patrick mahomes and lamar jackson
chiefs and ravens they met in the
regular season each of the last two
years both games were awesome we thought
they were on a collision course in the
afc championship game the ravens failed
to punch their ticket for that
appearance losing at home to the titans
but to me that's the one that's got the
potential to be the new manning and
brady because i think these two teams
are going to be in the postseason pretty
much every year we know the the chiefs
will be and i think the ravens are good
enough to be there as well and they're
going to keep crossing paths and i can't
wait for them to cross paths for the
first time in the postseason patrick
holmes lamar jackson my choice chris
yeah it's a good one there's no doubt i
mean it's not really a rivalry yet
because lamar has to win one of these
games but nonetheless i think the future
is bright in this matchup uh so i'm with
you there that certainly was at the top
of my list too okay i'm gonna go to one
you know i don't think gets quite enough
attention and that's russell wilson and
aaron rodgers to me that's that would be
the marquee
best qb rivalry we got at least it has
some real history behind it you know i
mean yes there's the nfc championship
game there's the playoff game this year
they've met in a number of regular
season games because the packers and
seahawks have both been you know the
cream of the crop and the nfc throughout
the rogers and russell wilson era so you
know right now of course russell wilson
aaron rodgers are two of the top five
best quarterbacks in the game and uh i
still look at that as being one of the
best rivalries in all the football if
not the nfc
yeah and you know what they have had
several postseason games not quite the
same regularity as peyton manning and
tom brady but that's one i hadn't even
thought of that wasn't on my list so
i'll give you some credit for that one
but the good news is i've got the rest
of my list wide open and i i i i thought
you were going to go in a different
direction and i'm tempted to go there
but instead i'm going to go with a pair
of quarterbacks who when they meet this
year have a combined age of 84.
first time ever new rivalry drew brees
tom brady same division both of them
competing for the all-time passing
touchdown record like steve carlton
and who was the other pitcher back in
the in the uh the 80s when they both had
the strikeout record they were going
back and forth it was steve karl and
somebody else and i can't remember who
else it was because
yeah it was nolan ryan and steve carlton
i think it was i don't know we'll look
it up anyway drew brees
tom brady same division meeting twice
combined age of 84.
uh that to me instantly becomes one of
the best rivalries in football yeah i i
was gonna i'm mad because i mean i i'm
disappointed the fact that you didn't
have wilson and rogers even on your list
just tells me your list can't be that
good i should have picked these guys
first i'm disappointed that i did that
uh but you're right i mean
it's not a rivalry that has history but
i think it's a rivalry that is real
because i think both of these guys are
very legacy aware i think they both want
to be towards the top of the list and
touchdown passes and do all that and now
it's going to get personal this year
with nfc south titles on the line and
you know play-off spots on the line let
alone the personal statistical rivalry
right there right now so uh that that's
that's that's pretty damn good i can't
really argue with that one all right so
this is to me this right now is where
you start to in my opinion you gotta get
offend here there's no great rivalries
like that are tried and true
as of right yet you know the next one
that jumps out to me more than anything
i guess one that you know we got a
little preview of this year
you know is desean watson and patrick
mahomes i think that's one i look at and
go oh that's this could be special for a
long long time i mean first off i think
in in my if i had to rank quarterbacks
in football right now
man i know i'm going my homes one and
i'm either going russell wilson or
deshawn watson as number two and you
know that's where and to me it's the two
the most physically gifted quarterbacks
in the game guys that you know like we
talked about with some of the draft
prospects earlier on mike i mean yes
they can take advantage of what's there
to be had but when there's nothing there
to be had man they can still make it
happen and that's what's special about
these guys and i would hope that this
year was just the first of many playoff
showdowns that we'll continue to see
between both of these two guys i think
they're electric and as fun to watch as
anybody in the sport
well we saw desean watson beat patrick
holmes in the regular season mahomes got
the revenge in the postseason but that's
another one where you know the texans
have to continue to win that division
otherwise be in the playoffs to set the
stage
for it and that's why you know if you
get a couple of teams where
individually they can run their division
they do become more likely to get
together and it was the colts in the
south and it was the patriots in the
east and they were more likely to come
across each other and then it became the
broncos in the west with peyton manning
more likely to come across the patriots
in the postseason next one for me
is a new rivalry but it's got a ton of
potential and it involves a couple of
short quarterbacks and i like being
around short quarterbacks because it
makes me feel not as short russell
wilson kyler murray kyle murray beat
russell wilson last year in his own
building and they're going to play each
other twice a year every year no matter
what and maybe at some point they'll
cross paths in the postseason but i i'm
fascinated by what that can become
because they do have those similarities
short of stature but both great
quarterbacks and some fireworks when
they play each other twice a year every
year for as long as they're both with
their teams
yeah well i think it's yeah something
again to watch for in the future a
little bit like mahomes and watson there
where we see the potential i mean kyla
murray is he's he's skill set wise very
similar to russell wilson that way uh
being able to make plays electric big
time arms so yeah i i'm with you for
them to face off twice a year that's
going to be a lot of fun to watch here
in the nfc west and of course the nfc
west is so talented and has so many good
offenses and quarterbacks as is uh it
just makes it one of the most exciting
divisions in football all right here
you know what do i do here do i go with
like an old reliable type of
up you know i have thought about big ben
and tom brady um
but i feel like that's so one sueded one
way to brady having the edge there i
don't know if i necessarily look at that
as a rivalry uh but i think i gotta go
with that i think it's with the one of
the few and only tried and true ones i'm
gonna go with big ben and brady i am not
that i expect it to be like anything
this year but we've seen them play a ton
in playoff football afc championships
regular season games um
big ben beat brady two years ago up in
pittsburgh so that's one to even though
i feel like brady has the great
advantage these are two super bowl hall
of fame type quarterbacks who do have
history now are they playing this year
that's what i couldn't remember
they're not they they will they won't
play they won't play until 20 no they'll
play in 20 18 19 20. they'll play in
2021 if they're both still playing
well i just didn't want to go with like
baker and lamar jackson yet i just feel
like you know again i was almost thought
about doing that as far as your
pick
uh man maybe i should have done that i
should have changed that but i went with
the historical
the historical rivalry over the new age
rivalry which i am intrigued by lamar
and baker mayfield but big ben and brady
i mean they did deliver a lot of good
fun meaningful football game moments
throughout their career when they faced
off each other as far as the patriots
and the steelers are concerned
and it's not unreasonable to think that
that they'll they'll both make it to
2021 and they'll both be playing next
year you're right you know
yeah yeah it looks like that could
definitely happen uh especially with
brady saying it all along and big ben
saying he feels as good as he's ever
felt so i would think they got two years
left back in them and it's 20 22 i don't
think 2021. oh it's 2022. never mind
yeah it's every four
so that that's not going to happen again
so that makes your pick even worse i was
trying to help you out i was fudging the
numbers a little bit to help you out and
it's not good they're never going to
play again unless they both what other
ones did you have to be awesome
um well i i tell you what another new
rivalry that has uh some real history
super bowl 51 matt ryan tom brady you
know we haven't talked about that at all
we're so caught up in drew brees and tom
brady but matt ryan gets to look across
the field and see that no good sob that
took away his super bowl ring four years
ago and they get to play twice a year so
i kind of like that one
well i you know it's fast i want to
change my pick first off i really do i
wish i just saw the producer said i can
change it if i want to um but but what i
find interesting though we don't even
talk about matt ryan and drew brees is
that rivalry like that that's you know i
had that written down but we don't seem
to give that respect maybe that it
deserves and why is that do you think
i i j you know
even though matt ryan won the mvp in
2016
i there's i i and i love matt ryan we've
interviewed him he's a great guy he does
great things for the community
there's just there's
i don't know what it is with matt ryan
but he's so easily forgettable among all
the other great quarterbacks isn't he i
don't know what it is but people we just
forget him
i i agree i mean yes the mvp here
brought his team to the playoffs the
very next year they were close to upset
in philadelphia in that divisional round
in 2017 but yeah i don't know what it is
either you know of course they weren't
very good last year uh he doesn't have
you know like a showman's personality
that way so he flies on the radar and i
think really ultimately again what
happens in a lot of these conversations
other than 2016 i just feel like the
saints have kind of controlled that
rivalry so that's where it's almost i
don't even look at it as a rivalry
sometimes because i feel like it's been
one-sided you know swayed to the saints
and drew brees and sean payton more
times than not
i think what really hurt matt ryan was
his third year in the nfl
2010
they had
the number one seed and they were on
track for the super bowl and the packers
came to town and destroyed them with
aaron rodgers in his third season as a
starter sixth year in the nfl and and
that was ryan's chance to really
establish himself so i you know it was
building it was building
and then it kind of went flat and it
just feels like it's been flat ever
since and then they have the super bowl
year the mvp year and they blow the 28-3
lead and we've never moved matt ryan
from that category of very good to
high-level top five franchise
quarterback yeah you're right he's
always on the fringe of it and i think
that's where you know ultimately i think
that's realistically where he was but
you're right there's that 2010 year you
know there's a super bowl year hey let's
not forget in 2012 they were hosting the
nfc championship game and up 17 to
nothing against the san francisco 49ers
and blew that lead and lost two so i
think you're right i think you kind of
pieced it together there the right way
way to go investigative lawyer mike
florio but i think you're right i think
that changed people's thought or
perception of him because of some of
those losses early in his career
why did neither of us pick russell
wilson and jimmy garoppolo they had two
spectacular games last year and they're
gonna have two more this year
well because i just feel like it's we're
talking about one guy who's amazing and
another guy that i think we're still
questioning and we
you know
wonder how good he really is you know i
think that's the big thing i just don't
think we could put jimmy garoppolo in
the status of russell wilson to say oh
that's a rivalry no i think you know
jimmy garoppolo's he's a good player
he's middle of the nfl but that's just a
guy that's on a great team you know
we're talking about quarterbacks who
have greatness associated with them no
matter what team or no matter what
situation their team is in and we just
haven't seen that from jimmy garoppolo
yet i feel like to put him in that
category
one more we overlooked on the way out
jack scott carson wentz how do we i
thought about it well no i wrote it down
but again like you know
you know they played some games where
carson hasn't been there not been
healthy he's been out it's just been
i just don't think it's kind of good you
know flourish into what we want it's got
potential definitely because i expect
them to be the kings of the nfc east
here for the time being but i'm really
disappointed with my ben roethlisberger
tom brady pick can i change it i don't
really like it i want to change it
uh look i go ahead go ahead change it
what's your official third and final
pick
hurry up uh i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
with matt ryan and tom brady
[Laughter]
oh so you stole one of my ideas
yes yes i am i like that i think that's
a good one yes thank you
let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports